taking over Hollywood keepin things
positive but people love to come for you
on social media how do you handle all
that how do you deal with that and teach
Sophia how to deal with that
the lovely anger-management that I've
been given from Corp I would started me
a couple times and yeah just passing
that along and fine and knowledgeable
way because kids really don't want to
hear anger management or be vaudeville
or just keep it quiet but I've learned
it now so anger management applied in
the real world and on social media okay
yes Sophie has done it with that anti
bullying it's like the bullying
anti-bullying month and I think Sophia
on her YouTube expressing how that hurts
her and those funds I think more kids
should express that whether in therapy
or on a YouTube channels and I think
it's gonna change society so I'm proud
of my daughter you did this show a
little bit ago what did you learn from
this experience that you still have to
do in your everyday life
Wow so family boot camp was amazing that
you know opening opening season I would
say I practice every day my boundaries
and I think choosing to live a life on
my own and my family and my parents
receiving that has been great I
definitely am super independent woman
out and it really feels good it set
boundaries with a different show you
were on Teen Mom walked away from that
do you that was a good boundary set you
know enough is enough of that narrative
and on to a new chapter in my life I was
gonna say to you learned maybe I did
learn a lot from dr. edge doctor be bad
boundaries about how I like my voice
should be heard especially with my
parents or productions and I think
that's a beautiful thing leaving this
production in a positive way yeah
walking away with something you didn't
walk away from Teen Mom with we saw you
recently open up that Jenelle had
reached out to you for advice with her
situation what exactly was she asking
you am i loud I'm you know what I
actually have like some big some big
stuff that I promised some executives
that Viacom that I would not be talking
about that but I wish all the Teen Mom
ladies Teen Mom is actually all the best
it's amazing yeah I maybe I'll be an
entertainment lawyer one day I think I'm
great at that
maybe yeah you can help all the girls
without all the things that you know
certification you know pass that bar
exam like I'll do it today if I could
but I'm busy writing a film
okay we're writing a film I was gonna
say what is happening in the world of
fair right now I was just sharing that I
have been working over a year with
screenwriting
turning my new ten to selling on Thor my
newer to the same book my teenage dream
ended into a feature film and I think
that sensationalism
and all that it's like you want to write
it perfect but what is perfect sometimes
you throw scenes out you don't want to
cast it's like that anymore so it's been
really hard because it's so close to my
art so I need to bring in another
production another part of the team to
get it wrapped up get it out in theatres
I'm so pumped all right so we're gonna
see your life story on the big screen
yes and I think that's good to see you
know how Sophia's dad Derick was in my
life and what that meant to me a lot of
ladies are widows they have loss they're
raising kids on their own now you think
it's such a it's a good time for
independent women and the film would you
ever bring your life back to the small
screen be it going back to Teen Mom or a
different show and new show I think it
could be big I mean I think Teen Mom
should definitely be taking over YouTube
on the airplane when I'm traveling all
over I mean maybe I'll have to work on
the distribution and business prep and
then maybe I'll come back do you stay in
contact with any of those girls or have
you put cut the cord a completely I'm
just blessed to have good relationships
with the executives and producers and
the people who I first met again so
that's great but I do wish all the other
ladies the best you know they're trying
when Sophia is growing up how is she
doing
Sophia is the big ten she's doing good
she's going to costumes every days she's
like a little star in her own way I'm so
blessed and thankful for my daughter
that I have yeah but it's it's a whole
new decade for me like we're not talking
about diapers than this and that and
babysitters in school we're talking
about like I'm growing here I'm wearing
a bra I'm thinking of a car it's been
really crazy summer has a literal
newborn to think she's ten that's why
she's my baby I can't wait okay there's
going to be another great mom and
daughter project you guys can see us
whether that's on our YouTube channels
or wherever out
[Music]
[Applause]